Hallo, guten Abend.
Ich bin Asasiden Ersin auf dieser Station und heute für Sie zuständig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, klar. Hauptsache irgendjemand hilft mir. Ich habe solche Schmerzen.
Ja, ich würde gerne so erst ein paar Fragen, so ihr ein paar Sonstinnen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Elke Brummer.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nach- und Vornamen buchtebieren?
Ja, der Familienname ist Brummer, B-R-U, Doppel-M-E-R.
Und der Vorname ist Elke, ganz kurz, E-L-K-E.
Okay, okay, Frau Brummer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 59 Jahre.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 1.02.64.
Am 1.02.64 ist gerade ein Monat her mein Geburtstag.
Okay, okay, herrlich, anglückwurscht.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin nicht groß, ich bin nur 1.57 und ich wiege 65 kg.
Okay, was fühlt Sie uns? Was fühlt mich wert, haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe solche starken Schmerzen.
Ich habe die Schmerzen auf der linken Seite im Rücken und das strahlt bis in den Bauch rein.
Vor einer Woche hatte ich das schon mal ein bisschen, aber dann ist es wieder weggegangen.
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen anhalten und das klopft so richtig.
Es strahlt bis in den Bauch rein und es sind wirklich heftige Schmerzen.
Es ist eigentlich so, dass es mir schon fast schlecht ist vor Schmerzen.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden? Seit einem Wochen?
Nein, vor einer Woche war das einmal und dann war es wieder besser, aber jetzt ist das seit gestern Abend spät.
Ja.
Ich habe dann auch mal Temperatur gemessen, weil ich mich so fieberig gefühlt habe.
Gestern Abend hatte ich 38.
Okay, das ist sehr gut. Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen? Medikamente, oder?
Erst mal habe ich noch nichts eingenommen, ich habe gedacht, es geht auch wieder weg,
die Schmerzen sind wirklich immer noch sehr heftig und es tut mir auch sehr weh,
wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe, wenn ich Wasser lassen muss.
Ich muss ständig zur Toilette, da kommt immer so ein ganz bisschen
und dann tut es so sehr weh, dass man am liebsten das gar nicht machen will.
Okay, wie sieht Ihr Urin aus? Das ist Herr, Politik, welche Farbe hat Ihr Urin?
Der Urin, so genau habe ich mir das nicht angeguckt, aber Blut habe ich da nicht bemerkt, auf keinen Fall, nein.
Okay, okay. Können Sie bitte diese Beschwerden genau beschreiben?
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, klopfen, starken, unknoten, diese Beschwerden werden wir noch formen,
und haben sie immer noch. Nein, ich stelle nicht diese Schmerzen.
Ja, ich stelle nicht. Okay, diese Schmerzen schützt auch in den Rücken und in den Beinen aus.
Nein, nein, nein, die Schmerzen sind im Rücken, also so im oberen Rücken, ja, auf der Seite.
Und sie strahlen in den Bauch aus.
Verstahlen in den Bauch aus. Ja. Sieht die Schmerzen dauerhaft?
Ja. Okay, okay, ich habe es nicht. Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel? Ja.
Haben Sie Erbruch? Nein, nein, ich musste mich nicht übergeben, ich musste nicht übergeben.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es praktisch von den Schmerzen, dass mir schlecht ist.
Ja, okay. Gibt es bestimmte Auflöser für diese Schmerzen? Haben Sie denn nicht?
Nein, das habe ganz plötzlich angefangen. Also vor einer Woche, da ist es gewesen,
als ich die Treppe hochgelaufen bin. Da war das ja mal, da habe ich einmal so etwas gehabt,
dass ich, das ist aber dann wieder weggegangen. Und jetzt ist es aber nicht wieder weggegangen.
Okay. War es Sie beim anderen Ausfall für diese Beschwerde?
Nein, damals ist es ja von alleine weggegangen, habe ich gedacht, okay, hat sich erledigt.
Und als es dann heute Nacht wieder los ist, habe ich ja jetzt, muss ich aber mal los, ja.
Okay. Ist Ihnen schwindelig? Schwindelig ist mir nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie verändert, kommt im Stuhlgang? Haben Sie durchfahrend oder verstoffen?
Ich verlor sowas nie, sowas habe ich nicht.
Hat sich der Stuhl in der Liste verändern, zum Beispiel eine Defibrillations-Gener?
Der Stuhl? Ja.
Nee, das ist immer alles gleich.
Okay. Sind Ihnen so aufgefahren?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, so aufbrennen, sowas habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Burutschmerzen, Herzschmerzen, Herzschöpfe?
Herzschmerzen, nein, ich habe Rückenschmerzen und Bauchschmerzen, aber keine Herzschmerzen.
Burutschmerzen, Herzschmerzen, ich meine, sind Sie...
Burutschmerzen.
Ja, Burutschmerzen, Herzschmerzen.
Nein, habe ich nicht. Ich habe Rückenschmerzen.
Okay. Müssen Sie in der Merks auf die Toilette gehen?
Ja, letzte Nacht musste ich natürlich alle nase lang auf die Toilette, ja.
Und das hat immer so weh getan, ne?
Okay.
Sind Ihre Beine geschwollt?
Ich bin nicht aufgefahren.
Okay.
Hat Ihr Gebi internetgesagt verändert?
Sind Sie ab oder so genommen?
Mein Gewicht hat sich nicht verändert. Nein, nein, leider, Gott, es könnte ja gut mal runtergehen, aber es tut es nicht. Nein.
Ich habe mich abgenommen.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, also heute schmeckt es mir überhaupt nicht, aber das ist halt, weil ich diese Schmerzen habe.
Aber normalerweise ist der nicht so schlecht.
Okay.
Ja.
Normalerweise nicht, aber jetzt bin ich halt, letzte Nacht habe ich nicht gut geslafen, weil ich denn nicht zur Toilette musste.
Okay.
Und eben auch diese Schmerzen hatte ich, das hat mich schon wachgehalten.
Haben Sie Ihr Babystall verwendet?
Nein, ich bin nicht unwächtig geworden. Nein.
Okay.
Sind Ihnen um irgendwelche Allergien geklappt?
Ja, ich habe eine Pflasterallergie, so dieses braune Pflaster, da kriege ich so juckende Hautpicklchen.
Und dann hat man auch mal festgestellt, dass ich eine Allergie auf Nickel habe.
Ja. Okay.
Sind Sie in der nächsten Jahre?
Ja, logischerweise bei meinem Alter, ne? Ja.
Ich mache das meist schon durch, aber manchmal habe ich noch so ein bisschen Beschwerden.
Okay.
Besuch uns Sie gerne mit Ihrer Frau, na?
Ja klar, einmal im Jahr gehe ich zur Krebsfroso, ja, ja.
War alles in Ordnung?
Bisher war immer alles, ja, okay.
Okay.
Sie sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Ja, ja, gegen Corona bin ich geimpft, ja.
Okay.
War Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland, oder hatten Sie eine Reise?
Hm, ich war mal in Österreich, aber ein paar Tage, aber das ist auch schon lange her.
Okay. Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Krankheiten, von denen ich wisten sollte,
wie Suckerkrankheit, Blutdruck oder?
Der Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch. Das ist schon seit fünf Jahren.
Dann nehme ich Kandisatan morgens ein.
Okay, wie viel Milligramm?
Dann nehme ich vier Milligramm.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Krankheiten?
Nein.
War das noch andere Krankheiten?
Ja, okay.
Ich habe, sonst habe ich nichts anderes, denn wenn ich jetzt Rögenschmerzen habe, ich habe, ja, klar.
Ja, wurde Sie schon einmal okuriert?
Noch mehrfach, ja, als Kind habe ich die Mandeln rausbekommen und die Blinden.
Und meine Tochter ist auch mit Kaiserschnitt auf die Welt gekommen.
Ja, okay. Wann war das? Mit welchem Alter war diese Operation?
Mit welchem Alter? Auf den Blick, also, da war ich 34, als meine Tochter auf die Welt gekommen ist.
Okay.
Kaiserschnitt, dann eine andere Operation und?
Und Mandeloperation als Kind, ne?
Okay.
Nehmen Sie noch Medikamente aus Erkannisarten?
Nein, sonst nicht nichts.
Okay.
Haben Sie kribbel oder taubreisgefühlt?
Im Bein?
Ist Ihnen taubreisgefühlt oder kribbeln am Bein aufgefallen?
Meine Beine? Da kribbelt nix? Ne.
Oder kribbeln, taubreisgefühlt? Aufgefallen?
Nein, habe ich nicht, ne.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Laufen stehen?
Na jetzt, weil mir der Rücken so betut, kann ich natürlich kaum laufen. Ja, klar.
Okay.
Haben Sie sich feinlich in der letzten Zeit?
Letzt habe ich mich nicht gefeinert.
Ich habe mich mal mit dem Archen gefallen, oder?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das fing mit einmal ganz von alleine an.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie früher Englische beschwerden?
Ich meine, ich habe das einmal...
Hab ich doch gesagt, dass ich das einmal hatte, und das ist aber da wieder weggegangen ist.
Okay, okay.
Rauchen Sie Zigarette?
Nee, sie geraucht habe ich noch nie.
Noch nie, okay, sehr gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke wieder ein Glas Wein oder ein Glas Bier im Sommer.
Oder mal ein Likör, das ist irgendwie aber sehr gelegentlich, würde ich sagen.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen habe ich keinen Kontakt. Nein, nein.
Okay.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen über Ihre Familie gestellt.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an ihr getwärtschen Krankheiten wie Blutdruck, Blutdruck, Zuckerkrankheiten?
Also mein Vater, der ist bekannt, dass er so eine Herzkrankheit hat, so eine Corona-Herzkrankheit.
Und meine Mutter ist schon vor einigen Jahren gestorben.
Ja, ganz blöd, die hat eine Bypass-Operation und das hat sie irgendwie nicht überlegt.
Okay, mein Beidat, haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite beim Einwohner-Meldeeamt.
Ja, ja.
Sind Sie sofrieden mit der Arbeit?
Ja, da ist natürlich immer viel los, aber das macht mir Spaß.
Okay, wie ist Ihre Familie statt?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter habe ich, ja.
Ich habe ja vom Keil das nicht erzählt.
Ja, ich glaube, sie ist 24 Jahre alt.
Ja, genau.
Mit wem nehmen Sie mit der Familie?
Ja, die Tochter ist natürlich aus dem Haus, aber ich lebe wohl mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Okay, treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, also hin und wieder gehe ich mal schwimmen im Sommer,
aber jetzt im Winter ist mir das zu kalt und jetzt gehe ich gerne mal zügig spazieren,
aber so richtig Sport treiben tue ich nicht.
Okay, ich habe meine Fragen, ich habe meine alte Fragen,
möchte Sie noch hinzufügen?
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich möchte wissen, dass man gegen diese Schmerzen machen kann,
woher kommen die?
Ja, ich kann noch nicht genaues Argum,
aber ich habe auch eine Frage,
wie die Brüder für die Brüder sind,
wie die Brüder für die Brüder für die Brüder,
wie die Brüder für die Brüder,
und ich nehme eine Brüder,
ich lege einen Zugang,
und ich lege einen Zugang.
Wir müssen erst einmal die Ergebnisse abwarten,
die Ergebnisse dauert ungefähr 30 Minuten,
je nachdem ich Ergebnisse habe,
sage ich Ihnen,
Ja, okay. Ja, gut.
Ja, gut. Ja, dann bin ich einmal gespannt, was noch so oft wie zukommt.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Habt ihr einen Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch Fragen?
Wie, wie ich dachte, ich schmerze?
Ah, ja, genau.
Genau.
Also, die sagt ja, sie hat tolle Schmerzen, ne?
Und sie gibt die an mit acht von zehn auf der Skala.
Und genau genommen müsste man da dann auch im Vorfeld sagen,
oh, wenn sie solche starken Schmerzen haben,
soll ich ihnen etwas gegen die Schmerzen geben
oder halten sie das noch aus bis zum Gesprächsänder oder so, ne?
Das, weil, also, die hat ja offenbar richtig starke Schmerzen, ne?
Wenn du die Schmerzen genau beschreiben,
sind es drückende, brennende oder siehende Schmerzen?
Drückend brennenziehend.
Sie stellt schwierige Fragen.
Also, es sind klopfende, starke Schmerzen.
Ich denke mal, sie sind am ehesten drückend, drückend ziehend.
Ja, vielleicht so.
Haben sie Fieber?
Hab ich gesagt, ja.
38, 8.
Haben sie Nackensteifigkeit?
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Haben sie Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, ordentlich hab ich auch gesagt, heftige Schmerzen.
Deswegen war ich dann ja auch wegen der Schmerzen,
war ich dann ja auch ein bisschen ungeduldig als Patientin,
als dann auch noch nach dem Herzen gefragt wurde
und nach den Beinen und nach Kribbeln.
Da bin ich ja irgendwo ein bisschen ärgerlich geworden, ne?
Sind Ihnen Lärmscheu oder Lichtscheu aufgefallen?
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Können wir anfangen und erst das hier schicken?
Ja, keine Frage.
Okay, dann schießen wir los.
Hallo, guten Abend Frau Obererstin.
Hallo.
Ja, ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen sie vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, die Patientin heißt Erke Brummer.
Sie ist 49 Jahre alt, geboren am
1.12.1964 und 1,47 Meter groß und 65 kg schwer.
Sie hat sich bei uns heute wegen seit gestern bestehenden,
drückenden, klopfenden Schütterke
und Rückenwunberg.
Rückenwunberg ist vorgestellt.
Sie habe 9,3,8 cm gemessen.
Sie hat 5,4 cm gemessen.
Sie hat eine ganze Menge gemessen.
Ja, ich hab das.
Was ist das?
Ich hab das.
Ja, das ist.
Moment mal.
Ich mach mir ein Mikro aus, bitte.
Hallo.
Okay.
Sie ist momentan in der Wächsengahne.
Sie besucht Regalmäßig ihre Frau aus.
Für Vorsorge und Untersuchungen.
Sie hat allergegegen Braufreister.
Braunes Frester?
Braunes Frester.
Sie sind vollständig geïft.
Auch Corona.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unaufwendig.
Sie hat vor Erkrankten geübt.
Sie hat nach technologies bulletin generational
Sie ist nicht traurig, sie trinkt geregert ein oder zwei Glas Wein,
die Drogenabus für die Verneidung,
und deswegen an einem Leise,
Leide der Vater, Coronarheißkrankheit.
Die Mutter ist vor einigen Jahren
am Mjokardinfarktus während der By-Pors-Operation verstorben.
Sie ist angestellt beim Anwohner,
und sie ist verheiratet,
und lebt mit ihrem Mann und habe eine Torte.
Die anaesthetischen Angaben
durch den Ames dann auf eine Piononephritis ein.
Was wäre differentialdiagnostisch möglich?
Das ist ein Schlecht.
Die Anwohner sind die Anwohner,
die im Schlecht sind.
Sie sind die Anwohner, die im Schlecht sind.
Ja, wie handelt man das denn?
Was heißt das denn mit dem Fachbegriff?
Okay, urolitiasis.
Ja, okay.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ja, ich werde erstmal körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, das habe ich jetzt gemacht.
Ich habe noch mal gemacht.
Ich habe auch noch mal gemacht,
ich habe auch noch mal gemacht,
ich habe noch einmal gemacht,
ich habe noch mal genome,
ich habe manchmal auch noch ein Veröffentliche gemacht,
Wie Blutdruck, Fibar, Temperatur.
Blutdruck, Temperatur.
Ja, nach dem Köpfernis,
Blutuntersuchung,
Blutdruck, Blutdruck,
Blutdruck,
Elektronik,
und je nach Nierenweite und Kulturentebiogramm,
werde ich eine Antibioterapie einsetzen.
Okay.
Ja.
Und wenn sich eine der Differenzialdiagnosen bestätigt,
dass sie zum Beispiel ein Steinproblem hat?
Was ist dann?
Ja, wenn es Steinproblem hat,
das kann schützeln, wenn es schützt.
Ich sehe es als wenn es schützt.
Dadurch können wir die Steine zeltrücken.
Genau, dann gehen die ab.
Ja, ja.
Oder,
oder Operation mit Operation.
Ja, das wäre dann.
Nächste Schritt.
Genau.
Okay, gut.
Ja, dann gucken Sie mal zu,
dass die Züge ihren Zugang bekommt,
dass die auch ihre Analgesie bekommt.
Und halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
das ist die Traubrummer,
was Sie da rausbekommen,
was dann tatsächlich hinter Ihren Beschwerden steht.
Ja, okay, gut.
Ja, dann vielen Dank und bis später.
Okay, danke schön.
Ja, was ist mir aufgefallen?
Die Zahlen, die Zahlen.
Sie hat gesagt, sie ist am 1., 2., 65 Geburtstag
und sie hatte gerade Geburtstag.
Und Sie sagen, sie hat am 1., 12. Geburtstag.
Also sie hatte am 1., 2. Geburtstag.
Okay, ich habe ein, 2., 7, aber falsch gesagt.
Ja, ich habe vorgegeben im Februar,
ein 1. Februar.
Ja, alles im Februar, das Geburtstag.
Genau.
Dann, ich gucke mal so in der Reihe nach, wie es runterkommt.
Sie haben unterschlagen die Nickelallergie.
Ja, wir haben sie der erste nicht verraten.
Das war alles okay.
Ja, was ein bisschen merkwürdig in der Formulierung war,
dass man sich an der Familienanamnese leide der Vater an KHK.
Also, das ist auch so ein Satz, da muss man sich,
oder so eine Situation, da muss man sich eine gute Formulierung überlegen.
Die Frage nach der Familienanamnese,
ergab für den Vater oder so.
Und das ist mir beim letzten Mal schon aufgefallen.
Das ist sehr, sehr empathisch, dass sie sagen,
oh, das tut mir leid, herzliches Beileid,
dass die Mutter gestorben ist.
Ja, aber gerade wenn das potentiell schon lange Zeit her ist,
dann kondoliert man eigentlich nicht mehr.
Wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ja, meine Mutter ist letzte Woche gestorben
oder vor zwei Monaten oder so, dann sagt man,
oh, ja, tut mir leid, herzliches Beileid, ja.
Aber ich würde das sonst so im Anamnesegespräch nicht machen.
Wenn das jetzt ganz was tragisches ist,
fällt mir gerade so als eine große Katastrophe ein.
Ich habe neulich von jemandem gehört,
wo der Zwillingsbruder gestorben ist.
Das ist natürlich so etwas, wo man dann sagt,
oh, das war bestimmt sehr schwer für sie oder so.
Aber sonst, wenn die Eltern, also auch jetzt nicht gerade
im ganz Jugendlichen Alter sterben,
dann würde man eigentlich nicht mehr kondolieren.
Ja, was ich so ein bisschen vermisst habe
in ihrer ersten Beschreibung der Beschwerden,
sie beschreibt ja eigentlich einen klassischen
und sehr heftigen Flankenschmerz.
Sie können nicht erwarten,
dass die Patientin selber den Fachbegriff Flanke benutzt.
Sie hat gesagt, da seitlich am Rücken.
Das ist keine Lumbagie, ja,
sondern sie beschreibt eigentlich den klassischen Flankenschmerz,
der in den Bauch reinstrahlt, ja.
Und muss man auch dazusagen,
der Schmerz ist plötzlich aufgetreten.
Wie viel spricht das?
Ja, akut.
Ja, auch, dass dann Stein ist.
Stein, ja.
Also es ist tatsächlich, es ist ja ne Urolithiasis.
Ja, also, und das ist ja eigentlich markant.
Sie hatte schon mal Beschwerden,
der Stein hat sich aber wieder irgendwie zurechtgeschön
und Schmerzen sind besser geworden.
Und jetzt hat sie hoch akut, ganz starke Schmerzen
und das macht so einen Entzündungsschub, ja.
Sie kriegt Fieber und stärkste Schmerzen.
Ja, das ist mit Epifuronifritis,
meine ich, nicht so richtig zu erklären.
Okay, ja, viel darf auch.
Ja, also das war ja eine ihrer Differenzialdiagnosen,
insofern, ne, das ist es dann auch ja wirklich gewesen.
Dann, ja, so ganz kleine Augenblick,
drei Mischteiden.
Bitte nicht, ich werde ihnen körperlich untersuchen,
sondern ich werde sie körperlich untersuchen.
Okay, ich weite.
Ja, ja.
Und genauso die Schmerzen strahlen in den Bauch aus, ja.
Und nicht in der Bauch.
Das sind so ein bisschen diese Grammatikfeinheiten.
Und ja, was klasse war, was sie untersuchen wollen,
dass da der Urinstatus gleich noch dazu kam,
gut war auch Beklopftschmerzen, ne.
Aber natürlich gucken sie nicht nur auf der linken Seite,
sondern sie gucken auf beiden Seiten, ne.
Ja, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Ja, und ja, was ich eben schon am Anfang gesagt habe,
was man sicherlich bei jemanden, der so starke Schmerzen hat,
überlegen sollte, ob man da schon im Vorfeld sagt,
wir machen, ob sollen wir ihnen Schmerzmittel geben,
damit sie das aushalten, oder eben auch,
wir machen eben kurz ein paar ganz schnell machtbare Untersuchungen,
damit wir ihnen zügig ein Schmerzmittel geben können.
Das muss man dann in der Prüfung natürlich angepasst machen.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie die Prüfer reagieren.
Aber ich denke schon, dass sie eigentlich zumindest das Angebot machen müssen.
Was mich als Patientin eben eigentlich so ein bisschen gestört hat,
das waren ihre vielen Fragen, die an meinen Symptomen so vorbeiging.
Ja, ich habe Ihnen ja eigentlich einen sehr klaren Fahrt gesagt,
wo ich meine Beschwerden habe,
und Sie haben aber Ihr ganzes Programm abgefragt.
Ja, und ich denke mal, wenn das eindeutig in eine Richtung geht,
dass man erkennen kann,
dass jemand Beschwerden, die mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit
in irgendeinem Problem liegen,
klar, dann kann ich noch nach den dicken Beinen fragen.
Das passt vielleicht noch, aber der will ich jetzt so...
Nicht logisch.
Bitte?
Ja, also nicht das ganze andere Programm mit abfragen.
Was für mich die Kribbelparastäsien zum Beispiel.
Das würde ja zu einer Lumbalgie gehören.
Da könnte man sich vorstellen, dass man eine Kribbelparastäsie im Bein hat,
aber ja, nicht jetzt bei den Nähenschmerzen.
Oder muss mich jetzt jemand korrigieren, wenn ich da etwas falsch sage?
Ja, also ich denke, man muss nicht komplett das ganze Programm abfragen,
wenn die Symptome so eindeutig in eine Richtung gehen.
Ich habe mich auch gewundert, dass jemand fragt,
nach Nackensteifigkeit.
Eigentlich habe ich keine Kopfschmerzen angegeben.
Was war da der Hintergrund?
Das würde mir jetzt mal interessieren, warum der Kollege das gefragt hat.
Derjenige, der das gefragt hat,
können Sie sich noch mal melden?
Ja, Ihr habt gefragt.
Ja, warum haben Sie das gefragt?
Weil sehr starker Schmerzen sind.
Deswegen denke ich, eine Menengitis oder...
Aber Sie haben doch kein bisschen Kopfschmerzen angegeben.
Ja, aber ich denke, Sie schmerzen eben Rücken,
deswegen denke ich hier...
Deswegen haben Sie eine Nervengeschichte gedacht.
Ja, Nervengeschichte.
Ja, aber danke schön, dass Sie das noch geklärt haben.
Also, für mich klingt es einfach so eindeutig,
wenn ich sehr geflangte Schmerzen in den Bauch ziehe.
Und ich habe ja zusätzlich eigentlich auch sehr typische Symptome beschrieben,
mit der Polarkissorie und mit den starken Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen.
Und dass da immer nur ganz wenig kommt.
Das sind alles Sachen, die für das Nierenproblem
und für den Stein sprechen.
Und dann ist es, meine ich nicht so,
was, was ich dann danach Herzklopfen, Herzrasen zu fragen,
vielleicht im Sinne der Infektion oder des Fiebers.
Aber Sie haben das auch gemerkt, die Patientin ist ja ein bisschen ungeduldig geworden.
Ja, und wurde dann ja, habe ich doch nicht,
ich habe doch gesagt, ich habe Rückgeschmerzen.
Also versuchen Sie wirklich, wenn der Patient was schildert,
diese Sachen auch wirklich zu notieren,
auch wenn Sie das noch nicht auf Ihrem Zettel haben.
Ja, also es ist noch nicht an der Reihe,
aber die Patientin schildert ein Symptom.
Irgendwas haben Sie noch mal gefragt, Augenblick, was war das?
Ich habe gesagt, ja, mir ist schlecht vor Schmerzen.
Und dann haben Sie nachher noch mal gesagt, ist Ihnen übel.
Habe ich doch schon gesagt.
Und auch strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus,
habe ich auch vorher schon gesagt.
Also die Informationen, die die Patientin von sich aus gibt,
schon wirklich gleich mitverarbeiten
und die Fragen dann als abgearbeitet erklären.
Das ist natürlich schwer, wenn die schnell redet.
Ich glaube, ich rede schnell.
Und wenn man sich nicht ganz sicher ist, kann man dann ja sagen,
Sie haben das vorhin erwähnt, habe ich das richtig verstanden.
Strahlen die Schmerzen aus.
Okay, ja.
Gut.
Ja, also das wären so meine Kritikpunkte,
dass ich denke, Sie haben ein bisschen zu sehr an Ihrem Schema geklebt,
anstatt auf die Patientin mit Ihren speziellen Bedürfnissen einzugehen.
Aber in der Schilderung gegenüber der Kollegin
haben Sie diese ganzen Sachen ja eigentlich auch gar nicht erwähnt.
Da sind Sie eigentlich nur auf die Leitsymptome eingegangen.
Sie haben jetzt nicht gesagt, das und das und das wurde verneint.
Das haben Sie nicht gesagt.
Das hatten Sie zwar die Patientin gefragt, die darüber ungeduldig war,
aber der Ärztin, haben Sie das nicht gesagt.
Wir stehen Sie?
Ja, ja.
Okay, gut.
Ja, also das wären meine Punkte, das würde ich Ihnen jetzt ans Herz legen.
Noch eine Sache.
Ja, das ist auch eine sprachliche Feinheit.
Voroperationen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie wurde wegen Tonselektomie und Appendektomie operiert.
Nee, Sie erhielt eine Tonselektomie oder bei ihr wurde eine Tonselektomie
und eine Appendektomie durchgeführt.
Ja, warum?
Also Sie wurde nicht wegen Tonselektomie operiert,
sondern die Operation war eine Tonselektomie.
Sie wurde wegen einer Blinddarmentzündung operiert.
Okay.
Aber und naja, gut, der Kaiserschnitt, das ist dann einordentlich.
Und Sie hatte einen Kaiserschnitt oder der Exiocesaria.
Noch besser.
Ja, gut.
Das war noch mal so ein sprachliches Ding,
was mir gerade hier noch auf dem Zettel aufgetaucht ist.
Ja, gut.
Also ein bisschen sprachliche Feinheiten könnten kritisiert werden.
Damit müssen Sie rechnen, dass die Prüfer da vielleicht auch nochmal nachfragen.
Ansonsten, wie gesagt, mehr gezielt auf die Beschwerden des Patienten eingehen
und nicht unbedingt auf dem ganzen Katalog bestehen.
Ja?
Okay.
Gut.
Dann denke ich mal, sind wir für heute Abend fertig.
Wir sehen uns am Donnerstag wieder.
Donnerstagabend sind wir schlauer.
Kann das weit, ist das schon der?
Morgen ist der erste?
Ne, Freitag ist Ihre Prüfung, ne?
Nein, nein, Donnerstag, 2.
Donnerstag, am 2. schon?
Ja, ja.
Ich hatte irgendwie am 3. gedacht.
Okay, ja gut. Also Donnerstagabend sind wir kluge.
Ja, gut.
Dann, alle anderen sehe ich am Donnerstag wieder.
Ja?
Und dann gibt es eine neue Analyse.
Gut.
Dann einen schönen Abend Ihnen natürlich, ganz viel Erfolg.
Ich halte Ihnen die Daumen.
Ja, machen Sie es gut.
Und ja, alle anderen sehen wir am Donnerstag wieder.
Tschüss und schönen Abend für heute.
Danke schön.
Ciao.